this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 66 Echo Charles
with me Dave Burke also here guest
appearance we just got done recording a
podcast so you figured you might as well
stay in the seat
hang out hang out a little bit longer
just stay here long enough to get caught
in traffic on the way home yeah that's
what you get from moving to Carlsbad
you could say you're gonna move to San
Diego you moved to Carlsbad
you got issues uh I I I what I want to
do is put myself on report today put
myself on report because I had something
take place that
normally doesn't happen to me normally
I'm pretty good but the fact that this
went on for as long as it did
I have to like reveal
and and take ownership of the situation
so I don't want to make it too crazy but
here's the deal so in my in at our gym
Victory MMA I have a locker we all the
instructors we have lockers
I actually have two of them top and
bottom so I got like one Locker thing
they're pretty big lockers they're not
like a little tiny school locker but
it's where I keep all my Jiu Jitsu gear
you know t-shirts knee pads shorts
whatever headgear if you need it you
know geez so all this stuff
my top the top Locker is the one I
usually use so I have to bend down and
like get on my knee you know super
Comfort sure but there's some items
that um you're not using all the time
and so I bought for my top Locker years
ago I bought a little shelving unit from
Home Depot which is three minutes from
here
it's probably 10 years ago I bought a
little shelving unit for my top Locker
maybe eight years ago went built it all
of a sudden it saves so much space it's
great
about three years ago
I bought another shelving unit for my
bottom my bottom locker yeah
and it sat in the bottom locker the
shelving unit unassembled just sat in
the bottom locker
for
three years and I didn't
didn't follow through and Carry Out
actually building this shelving unit for
the bottom locker
just so everything would be squared away
and everything to be organized just just
so just just so everything could be
squared away and everything could be
organized which is
so nice in life
so for the past three years
I've just had the top one kinda squared
away but not really because there's
stuff that need to be moved to the
bottom one but I didn't because it was
kind of cluttered already because I
didn't have a shelf in there
and I just dealt with it and you know
it's probably about a 20 minute job
right and I knew that in my head because
I've done it before it's gonna take me
20 minutes to build out this bottom
shelf for my bottom locker
for three years I didn't do it for three
I could come in 20 minutes early yeah
and you know what it actually would save
you about probably one to two minutes
every day because you gotta kind of jam
stuff in there a little bit to get it
locked you know the top lockers I'm only
using the top one so but now I gotta
like push something back in or something
kind of slips out so it's kind of a pain
and finally
the other day I got done rolling at six
o'clock at night and I'm getting ready
to go home and my daughter was teaching
class and she's like sees me and she's
like hey Dad can we roll and I go well
I'm heading home she's like oh come on
I'm heading she was heading back to
college soon
I said okay what time are you done with
class she goes 6 30. so I have a half an
hour to kill
sure so I'm like oh I roll in there and
I just get to it
and I get it done in 18 minutes
and these two lockers
became ten times more squared away ten
times maybe 12 times more squared away
yeah
and every time I've come into the gym
since that time which has now been like
a month every time I've come in I've had
like a sense of relief and satisfaction
yeah
I didn't do it though
why didn't the thing that's weird is I
am not a procrastinator right like I
know there's times when I procrastinate
it's like oh I got squat day sometimes
I'll be like stretch for an extra 15
minutes and I know it's happening and I
actually will build that into my
schedule a little bit yeah yeah but I'm
not I'm not a person that goes oh maybe
not now you know I don't really do that
and here's something that I did it for
three years
of pathetic procrastination to do a task
part of it was because the let's face it
a minute a day
a minute of inconvenience I just was
like ah it's not that big of a deal yeah
yeah
and it's pathetic
my point in saying this is what is going
on in your life
that could take a 15 a 20 minute
investment or maybe it's a one day
investment or maybe you know because
sometimes that stuff happens too you got
something in your house you're like hey
if I if I pull down this fence and
reinstall a better gate I can get in and
out of it with the groceries and it's
going to make my life easier for forever
yeah but it's going to take eight hours
for me to pull down this old gate and
put up a new one and you just hold off
hold off hold off it reminds me
unfortunately
in Iraq
like I went to a we we hit a Target in
Iraq and the place we went into is like
you know this family's house and it was
just all jacked up and the the the the
trench was right next to the sink
where they prep
food yeah and I was like yeah if I lived
here I would start fixing this right now
if I moved in there I would immediately
start fixing this when we would go and
take over like a building to go live in
in Iraq
we would immediately start fixing stuff
like immediately like oh we can I can
put this over here I can but I can I can
build a little thing I can build a desk
I build desks for myself build beds from
everyone did this you just immediately
start improving stuff
so here I was for three years not
improving my situation
and it reminded me that that's common
it can be very common and it reminded me
not to let it happen again
so I wanted to put myself on report in
order to free up
the brains and lives of everyone yeah
well that's real I mean I was about to
say hey don't be too hard on yourself
but I'm not going to say that because
hey do what you did you sound like you
solved your little problem there
but it's like I figured it out I figured
what okay as you could probably imagine
that happened to me all the time very
common for me one was like um you know
how like in your kitchen you have
cupboards right yeah somewhere up top
some are down low usually down low well
in my case there's like pots and stuff
down there right so I had this one where
kind of what he called the hinge was
like off like the screw like came out of
the thing
not fully just so you know how there's
two hinges it was on the top so you
could open it a little bit but if you
open it all away like the door will like
fall all the way off and you kind of
know that right but if all you got to do
is open and just sort of hold it there
same as you grab the pots and stuff you
close it you're good to go
so but it's kind of a pain in the ass to
hold it but once you're done this is why
this is why same thing with you right
you're not thinking about that all day
yeah probably grab pots one time a day
maybe true you see I'm saying just like
you you whatever and you go roll you
don't think about that thing so you're
like whatever that's a good point even
though every single encounter with it
it's like that little pain in the ass
that little pain ass and it's the
Spectrum certain things are you know
play a bigger role in your day for sure
but that's what I was feeling I was like
whatever and then I literally forget it
but then one day I was just like men for
a while I don't even know why I did it
but I was like all right and I went and
grabbed another screw took out the old
one made another hole for three minutes
yeah literally like three minutes and
just like you every time I go to get the
pots and I'm like oh this is so
luxurious it seems I don't know if it
saved me time necessarily but effort
I'll tell you mental energy
but it's like we have this mental like
momentum that's why because we're like
hey if I'm gonna grab some pots or
you're gonna go Roll Jiu Jitsu you're
thinking about training you're not
thinking about putting together a shelf
yeah shelving the unit done rolling and
I get get in there and I'm like whoa I'm
gonna go time to go home get home get
food get start working whatever exactly
right you don't want to stop that
momentum and then put together a Ikea
shelving unit yeah it's not time for
that right now some other time but the
thing is it never works like that you
never wake up and be like you know what
today I'm gonna put together that
shelving you know the thing that
inconvenienced you for like one minute
yeah so it's like you know you got to
kind of like how you said you gotta
consciously check yourself yeah
understanding and appreciating
the Improvement in your life is
important it's important here's some
here's something I I thought of three
while you're explaining three that I
three what other scenarios oh gosh this
is like a lifestyle for you
yes sir Dave do you even have one
scenario are you just on it no I'm I'm
thinking more uh generically on why I'm
what I'm really procrastinate about and
what I'm not okay and I guess partially
to come to your defense a little bit
if there's something that needs to get
done that impacts like the life of my
wife specifically and to a large degree
to my kids I try to balance that a
little bit
that stuff just gets done it just gets
done and and I don't do it because I
like think I'm a great husband or a
great dad but I have this sense of like
dude I gotta get that thing done if it's
something that solely benefits me
and I can't really draw the connection I
am I will sit on things just like suck
it's super random as it sounds I have a
towel bar in the bathroom of the office
that I use that has been off the hook of
the wall and the towel just sits on the
on my uh counter the bathroom counter
yeah my daughter came in like four days
ago the towel bar had pulled off from
the hinge of the wall and she came into
my office I was working I I wasn't like
with a client but I was working and
she's like hey this thing broke and I'm
like I went downstairs got the
screwdriver got the drill got the new
anchors in like you know 17 minutes
later whatever five minutes later
my thing is still just sitting on my my
kitchen or my bathroom counter I don't
know when I'm gonna do it even though I
should yeah so I rationalize it by going
oh it doesn't help anybody else I'm not
gonna do it
yeah so you could rationalize your words
like that's just for me it's not really
putting me out much right but it's kind
of like what if every time like I saw
you not when we were talking but when we
weren't talking I'd like jab you in your
rib or something and it's like hey like
whatever it doesn't but if the day I
stop jabbing you bro you're gonna feel a
lot better I'll tell you that right now
yeah it's true
throwing things away
a lot of people procrastinate because
you know maybe you got to cut it up you
got to break it down it's you know it's
a five minute job
to throw this thing away but once you
throw it away it'll be gone then you can
park what kind of things are you
hoarding by the way stuff in the garage
which brings me to number two so like a
lot of times you know you put you buy
something or something old but while I'm
while I'm up here just just put myself
on report
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the the Jocko underground
podcast so if you want to continue to
listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized